I think about red-tailed Hawks a lot
because where I live in Los Angeles
there's two red-tailed Hawks that are
constantly circling around look and I
can see that they're looking for food
but they're gorgeous they're beautiful
and when the light it's your hair it's
looking like they see some blood on the
ground you know yeah they think I'm
circling they think a fox is a little
baby fox is sleeping on my head yes I've
been attacked maybe 18 times I should
probably I should probably stay inside
the house I'm constantly being attacked
by red tail ducks but they're really
gorgeous and when the sun catches them
just right and you see the color uh in
their feathers it's beautiful those are
great animals are they friendly when you
just have them perched on your arm and
do they do they cuddle uh no I have one
bird that is pretty friendly named Floyd
he's a Harris Hawk hair socks are
interesting though because they're the
only raptor in the world known to hunt
and pack so they have an ability to form
these social bonds that other Raptors
typically don't have so Floyd is the
exception with all my Birds he's pretty
friendly he loves meeting people I let
people hold him and pet him and stuff
but yeah no cuddling he's online a lot
he's got a lot of friends online
he's constantly gaming the keyboard
Warrior
so the other Hawks are in cells yeah
yeah oh wow I mean that is I I think you
would look like the ultimate cool badass
you know you've got such a great look
and then to think of you walking around
with one of these amazing Birds on your
arm where are they they're one room over
from me can you get one do you want me
to get them now is that okay I can yeah
sure just let me take the headphones off
of it all right okay oh that's cool what
if she comes back and it's clearly just
a phantom it's a stuffed animal and and
it's clear this whole time that she's
insane and she's like this one's called
you know chakra and it's a little Tigger
the tiger just a soup spoon here we go
oh we're gonna find out very soon
all right so I haven't created up and I
saved some food for him so I could feed
him while we're talking it's a beanie
baby
oh my God holy [ __ ] this is why I
decided to feed him now because he's
very fatty look at oh what are you
giving it oh oh my God what is she
eating that's an esophagus you just fed
him an esophagus oh my God what the hell
is that what is that it's like Predator
rips out a spine what is that
it's quail
[Laughter]
oh I can't have a conversation with that
to happen I can I certainly can
um by the way his table manners are
awful yeah he's just right that's the
way my brother Neil eats a veal at the
table it's just look at him go look at
the doubles over his meal all right so
you always just have like a a quail
thorax flying around
you always have a rabbit lungs and he
likes entrails right
um I usually get rid of the intros this
is you're looking at a quail neck I see
I identified it correctly I thought that
was the esophageal tract of why I
assumed a quail well this is going to be
sad but does he eat that little dangly
thing that falls out in front of his
face you know that little thing that
Quails have that little Periscope that
little feather Periscope thing the
feather on like the top of their head
yeah that that's what a quails no he's
he's feather intolerant he can't have he
drinks feather-free milk oh my God
that's too big a bite look out buddy
it's gone now is that enough meal for
him for how long is that a day it's
worth two days two days worse yeah I
mean if I in the wild they'll eat much
bigger meals than this than not have to
eat for several days but I my birds are
all trained and working so they eat uh
portioned out meals every day do you
discourage uh snacking late in the day
you know every now every now and then
pop yeah from the fridge
yeah every now and then you're just like
you know when you when you when you eat
it when you eat a field mouse don't eat
a field mouse just before dinner because
I mean just before bedtime because you
that's going right that's going right to
his thighs
um wow look at that what an impressive
bird I think he's relaxing now he just
recognized me yes he did he heard your
voice he's hurt my voice he saw me
anyone I know him he's gonna get violent
he's got a lot of uh good YouTube
content I've seen yeah when you say
these birds work what do they do are
they in shows or something so this this
Floyd he's a Harris Hawk and he is
trained to scare nuisance birds away
from places where they're unwanted like
Soul stir seagulls and crows pigeons
that sort of thing so we do a lot of
golf courses Resorts landfills uh water
treatments what about like airports
where they want to keep birds away from
uh the airplanes yeah definitely God
what an impressive bird that is oh my
God I'm just trying to oh he found a
piece oh good take all you want but eat
all you take
that's the rule I like he's a member of
The Clean Plate Club
he's eating his own foot yeah that's
okay pieces of quail on it every piece
every piece counts Roxanne you are such
a badass
are people intimidated by you like I'm
just you know I'm a total dork I no
impossible no you are not a dork you are
I think you're the coolest woman I've
met in in my entire life yeah I swear to
God falconry happens to be the coolest
bird thing you can do but it's still a
bird thing I I disagree completely I
just
um I'm I'm just blown away yeah and
absolutely blown away it's incredible
yeah it's very impressive